[Música]
la cantante colombiana Shakira será
juzgada en España acusada defraudar el
equivalente a unos 15 millones de
dólares en impuestos entre 2012 y 2014
porque la fiscalía pide 8 años y dos
meses de cárcel y una multa de unos 25
millones de dólares aproximadamente
analizamos la situación de la colombiana
y también la regularidad de este tipo de
casos por parte de personas influyentes
en este país y hablamos con Carmen jover
ellos profesora de fiscalidad de la
universidad pompeu fabra Gracias Carmen
por estar con nosotros esta mañana de
miércoles en directo América de Francia
24 empezamos por el caso de Shakira
podría ganar este juicio Porque además
Shakira está tan confiada en ganarlo y
no pactar digamos antes lo que lo que le
estaba pidiendo la fiscalía como para no
ir a un juicio que además es un proceso
como ya lo sabemos bien desgastante Qué
pasa Precisamente en este caso para allá
ir pues hablando de toda la fiscalidad
como lo estábamos adelantando antes
Pues bien aquí el tema principal es
determinar dónde vivía ella en esos años
que que le están imputando un delito
fiscal dónde vivías y realmente vivía
Pues en Colombia en Bahamas en Barcelona
lo que está determinando la
administración tributaria es que esta
señora durante esos años vivía en
Barcelona y Cómo se determina que vivía
en Barcelona pues determina que había en
Barcelona la ley en concreto no dice la
forma de determinarlo son signos
externos por ejemplo cómo las tarjetas
de crédito se usaban donde Bueno pues se
ha visto que hay muchas de sus tarjetas
de créditos usaban en Barcelona en días
laborables y fin de semana ella ha
acreditado ha intentado acreditar que
esas tarjetas de crédito Aunque estaban
a su nombre las utilizaba algún personal
a su servicio también la ley española
dice que a no ser que puedas demostrar
lo contrario tú tendrás tu residencia
fiscal y por lo tanto vas a tener que
pagar todos tus impuestos
en aquel país donde vivan tu cónyuge y
tus hijos su hijo estaba escolarizado en
Barcelona por lo tanto si también es un
indicio de que vivía en Barcelona cómo
va a acabar esto Pues no lo sé porque
evidentemente esto está en sede judicial
pero todo va a depender de si esos
indicios porque no hay nada Claro que
determinaron o no recibía en Barcelona
seguro el juez va a determinar si todos
esos indicios que aporta la fiscalía y
la administración tributaria y como los
está intentando destruir y Shakira pues
a ver qué valen más y los indicios que
aporta la administración tributaria o la
rotura de esos indicios que aporta
Shakira O sea que el final solo podrá
determinar un juez claro también digamos
que además de la multa en
aproximadamente 25 millones de dólares
sino sino recuerdo mal piden cárcel para
Shakira podría digamos eventualmente es
pagar años de cárcel Shakira Depende de
lo que diga el juez podría ella apelar
podría va a pelar una reacción
domiciliario la cárcel vacío
sí la cárcel en el caso de temas como
delito fiscal en España el delito fiscal
necesita dos requisitos dos requisitos
que los haré unos un requisito objetivo
que es el importe que defraudado por
impuesto y por año a Shakira se le está
pidiendo el impuesto sobre la renta y el
impuesto sobre el patrimonio por si
alguno de estos por año y por impuestos
supera los 120.000 en este caso euros
que sucede porque el total supera los 20
millones por lo tanto ese requisito
objetivo que es el importe lo supera
Pues ahora Necesitamos el segundo
objetivo para que realmente haya delito
fiscal y el juez pueda determinar que
deba ir a la cárcel pues el concepto de
delito fiscal el segundo requisito
imprescindible es el dolo el dolo es el
afán de delinquir el que ella era
consciente que lo sabía que sabía que no
estaba pagando impuestos Y eso el único
que lo va a poder determinar es el juez
si realmente el juez determina que había
dolor que ella era absolutamente
consciente por activo por pasiva porque
quería o por desconocimiento Pero porque
dejaba en manos de sus asesores y sabía
que se estaba ahorrando impuestos Pues
si el juez determina que realmente ella
era consciente Sí sí que puede ir a la
cárcel es un delito que está regulado en
nuestro Código Penal y puede ir pero ya
digo que va a ser un tema Pues de prueba
y de juicio y también le diré como
curiosidad que en España hay más
personas en la cárcel por delito fiscal
más asesores Fiscales que el propio la
propia persona que comete el delito
porque muchas veces los asesores
fiscales son los
colaboradores necesarios claro que el
propio contribuyente a lo mejor no tenía
ni idea Pues en España hay más asesores
Fiscales que el propio contribuyente
Pero eso todo va a depender de las
pruebas y lo que determina el juez
eso le quería eso le quería comentar
Carmen que analicemos un poco digamos el
caso español son bien duras las leyes
Fiscales en España también porque lo
hemos visto con otros figuras
prominentes cantantes jugadores de
fútbol digamos Porque estos casos son
tan sonados sobre todo en España
precisamente
pero los no famosos pues también hay un
montón de casos de contribuyentes que no
salen en la prensa y que le sucede lo
que está pasando aquí qué pasa con las
normas españolas Pues que el tema
principal en la mayoría de casos es el
tema de la residencia si la
administración tributaria demuestra que
era residente has de tributar en España
por tu renta mundial da igual donde la
obtengas Entonces qué sucede en algunos
casos famosos como también han salido
futbolistas no que montan un entramado
de empresas
trasladan sus ingresos Pues a lo mejor a
otros países o a través de sociedades
pero la ley española dice que si tú eres
residente en España has de tributar aquí
por tu renta mundial entonces lo que
sucede es que cuando deshacen este
entramado de sociedades ven que al final
por ejemplo no sé algún caso en el que
algún futbolista había transmitido
algunos derechos de imagen hombre Es
evidente que si yo transmito mis
derechos de los puede explotar una
sociedad pero la imagen la pongo yo o
sea es un ingreso que una parte
importante ha de ir a mi declaración de
renta y es por ahí por donde suelen ir
los casos de delito fiscal Es evidente
que los que salen la prensa son de
famosos pero pero también hay mucha
gente no famosa que también está
procesada por delito fiscal es decir
Carmen que por poner un ejemplo simple
si yo vivo en España Pero toda mi
riqueza está digamos alrededor del mundo
yo tengo que pagar los impuestos en
España por residir en ese país no
importando así yo no tenga digamos no sé
una cuenta de banco con tanto monto en
España
si tú eres residentes de tributar aquí
por tu renta mundial pero siempre has de
leer el convenio de doble imposición con
ese país Imagínate que tú resides pues
en España pero que tienes no sé una
cuenta en Colombia que te ha dado un
montón de intereses pues hemos de leer
que en este momento no lo tengo delante
y no no podía faltarlemos de leer el
premio de doble imposición España
Colombia que dice pues un residente en
España que tenga ingresos de cuentas en
Colombia donde lo ha de declarar la
mayoría de convenios ahora voy a
generalizar y cuando generaliza siempre
pierdes eh la mayoría de dicen que
cuando alguien reside en un país y tiene
rentas en otro dice podrá tributar en
los dos países eso es lo que dice en
general Eso quiere decir que a lo mejor
a lo mejor he de tributar en España y de
tributar en Colombia pero como yo soy
residente en España y declarar esos
ingresos en España y me puedo contar una
parte de los impuestos pagados en
Colombia